in the eye but Ninja Gaiden Z's story
mode you unlock a diary entry in which
the author talks about how he's happy
that he got to drop his dick and get
into some action he's glad for the
opportunity to get a blood boner as he
called it
perhaps Ninja Gaiden disease
excruciating writing could have been at
least somewhat overshadowed by great
action sadly even Ninja Gaiden Z
striking art style and obscene attitude
aren't enough to cause blood boners not
in a game this clumsy and poorly
structured sovereign in Geneva is
clearly not meant to be liked as he
pursues his revenge quest versus Ninja
Gaiden mega star Ryu Hayabusa then again
no one comes across as particularly
interesting or charismatic not even your
guide miss Monday whose primary
character traits are her monumental
breasts at least the action provides
some initial compensation for the game's
disastrous attempts to be funny
you wade through cartoons zombie hordes
using your sword your flail your metal
fist and every so often weapons that
fall an enemies drop when encounters are
kept simple the action is shallow but
satisfying in that dynasty warriors kind
of way in which you press buttons and
blood splatters all over your television
screen
my favorite standard weapon is the flail
it's long reach makes it useful for
ripping through a large number of
lurching zombies at once its ability to
create havoc is commendable allowing you
to make numerous foes simultaneously
vulnerable to a gory execution such
executions can be changed together in
quick succession with you pulling a
shoulder button with one execution
causes to move on to another not only is
there some innate glee and seeing zombie
heads fly into the air an undead body
split in half the torso but performing
executions rewards you with cubes that
replenish your health fear sadly the
shallow fun has quickly dropped in favor
of frustration the fixed camera is a
frequent problem sometimes forcing you
to fight off unseeable enemies without
giving you a proper view of your
surroundings and other times swooping
around when you cross a threshold in the
midst of combat the camera angles are
even less helpful during the repeated
boss battles in which a large robotic
Walker looms in the foreground and your
dashing around behind it hidden from you
as if to mimic ninja guidance famously
high level of difficulty Ninja Gaiden Z
fills the screen with Hulk's that fling
fire jilted brides that sizzle with
electricity and mutants that puke vile
in your direction but where games like
ninja gaiden black gift you with precise
combat systems that reward skillful play
Ninja Gaiden Z takes the cheapest
approach to difficulty imaginable
throwing so many of these enemies into
the arena that skill is barely relevant
sparking enemies teleport to your side
and slap you around while your dashing
around to snuff out the flames engulfing
you killer clowns knock you into
submission when you're rushing away from
suicidal grenadiers blocking and
countering certain attacks as possible
but rarely a viable tactic given how
randomly this mess plays out on screen
there's just no rhythm to the combat
Ninja Gaiden Z so called chemistry sad
exacerbates the frustration when certain
elements come in contact with each other
like the biological spew of a bluster
sister and the flames of a holy roaster
they cause interactions the chemistry
set is perfectly fine when you use it to
solve the game's mild puzzles but the
storms that suddenly ignite on the
battlefield when fire and lightning meet
are more hazardous than the threats they
alleviate as a result death is of
frustration and not a teaching tool and
your primary method of healing that is
collecting those post execution health
drops is unreliable the prompts to
execute enemies might appear in the
middle of one sword swinging and
vanished just as quickly when the second
half of your combo rips the vulnerable
enemy to shreds so much for that blood
boner then not that you'd be able to
keep it up during the game's first major
showdown which drops to single digit
frame rates in the heat of battle still
high but Ninja Gaiden Z keeps pumping
out the blood hoping to turn you on with
its gory combat and fall of your
attitude every so often the game would
get me excited particularly during its
high-flying parkour sequences that had
me stringing gymnastic moves like I was
a cyber Olympian the rest of the time I
could only shake my head at all the
wasted possibilities
aren't you a miserable piece of [ __ ]
[Music]